it's an honor that i that me walking in
my truth
me walking in my skin me walking in my
shoes
opens doors for other people to be able
to do that
in the biggest capacity ever you know
and and
i think at the end of the day if we
really start to show
true representation on the screen i
think it will start to
relay in other areas in society like the
government
i strongly feel like if you see it
that's when you can believe it and
that's when you can be
it and that's just like that's just the
minimum
of what you're able to accomplish so if
being
bad woman is the minimum i mean the sky
literally is the limit
time to be powerful
i met the new girl she's going to be a
handful
well first of all javisa thank you so
much for chatting with us
we at et are so excited for you to take
over
the batwoman mantle for season two of
the show
how are you feeling right now i'm
excited i'm super excited we worked so
hard
uh we worked really hard to come back
from what i think
you know people thought would break us
and i think that
i'm just i'm really proud of our team
for making magic because to me i've
watched the first two episodes and i'm
i really love them i love what we
created
so i'm excited i'm excited for the world
to see it her mom died in childbirth
i can't find a job father died before
she was born because i don't have a home
because no landlord wants to rent to an
ex-con
on post release and i love the fact that
ryan brings a completely different
perspective to the role of batwoman than
kate kane did can you talk a little bit
about that
yeah you know ryan represents a
community i feel like on
especially within gotham that had backs
turned on them for a very long time
you know and i think that this is a
world in that
in gotham that we've never seen before
that we'll finally get the highlight
and it's going to make it so real
because a lot of the issues are going to
get discussed
obviously throughout the season are very
relevant to what's happening in our
society
um versus it being too far but it's
still fun and still imaginative it's
still
you know gotham but we're going to bring
it we're going to bring some real life
situations into play
so when i look at ryan i think ryan is
the perfect vessel for that to happen
because she has one foot in that world
she comes from you know being a foster
kid going from foster home to foster
home and
everyone turning their backs to her and
and not having anyone to care
and love her so now she has a foot in
the world of
bat woman where she doesn't have money
but everything around that woman is all
about the
the fame and the wealth and the
accessibility um
so to have a superhero you know don
the the cow and the cape and come from
this
other world doing that i think it's
gonna show true representation within
gotham
that's really necessary so i think
people are going to have fun
they're going to connect to ryan because
of that and more than anything i think
they're going to connect to ryan because
they're going to see her go through this
journey
no one cares that the dope wasn't mine
or or that the crows were dirty or that
i'm actually a decent human
that is not having power that is the
very definition
of powerless e.t recently talked with
ruby rose and she
expressed how excited she was for you to
be taking over the cowl
and stepping into this role she looks
amazing she's gonna be amazing i can't
wait to see season two but i do know
that they're like that's
the old cow and so obviously i think
she's obviously gonna take that over for
a bit and i can't wait to see when they
kind of adjust and make the changes for
her as well i think it's gonna look sick
i'm curious have you guys had any
interactions at all or any conversation
no i haven't we haven't
was there anything that you saw from her
first season performance
that you were like okay like i see
that's how she did that here's how i'm
gonna put my
own spin on things you know what um
ryan is a completely different character
so i think naturally it just happened
right i didn't have to intentionally do
anything when
naturally ryan is she's too silly and
very determined yeah
and so they're so they're so different
that it naturally happens without me
having to feel the need to
lean more towards any kind of direction
we've done the work
you know caroline dries our amazing show
creator has created her in the writing
writer's room have done such an amazing
job
creating a story that we can get lost in
and i kind of just use that
and i leave with that every time i show
up on step i've been trapped
in a life surrounded by criminals i know
how they think
how they act but most of all i know how
to stop them and i think one of the
things that fans are going to be
so intrigued by her is that she makes
being
batwoman fun like she thinks this is
cool
was that energy something you were
excited to bring to your character
yeah and i think it naturally happens
because that's how i feel
it's so weird if there's any person that
is a superhero that doesn't feel like
this is cool come on out
like you're too cool if you don't think
this is cool um and so
when caroline and i talked about ryan
one of the things that she really wanted
to bring
in ryan's character is a comedy
i'm not the smoothest person i tend to
trip and fumble a lot
i tend to like you know all of which you
consider to be a very flawed human
and i'm trying to be this cool bat woman
but i have trouble getting out of the
batmobile because it sits so low and my
my cake keeps getting caught in the door
and so it just naturally happens that i
am like this
you know not good well i guess you can
say goofy but like this just
unsmooth superhero and it's just i think
it's flattering to be able to watch and
have fun and not take myself that
serious
oh look new batwoman once
they were crafting the new suit for you
and making it
your own and we saw that first look
image and we see you rocking those
gorgeous
curls like how much input did you have
in the new creative direction of the
batwoman suit
so caroline our show creator and
our lead costumer maya manny they are
the ones that really did the magic when
creating the suits
however i do know that like one of the
things that really inspired caroline was
fan art she was so inspired by fan art
so what we would do is we would send
each other
fan art of like that we love that we
felt could be
somewhat of what inspired the idea of
where we were going to go with the suit
but more than anything a lot of the fan
art um incorporated the hair
because my announcement picture i had
like this big curly fro
and so that's how if you didn't know me
that's the only picture you'd ever seen
of me so when you create a bad woman
she has this big curly fro and caroline
and i looked at each other like
this is it we got to do this we got to
do this and so that was like one thing
we knew for sure
with that our bat woman was gonna have a
big curly brow don't kill me but i made
some alterations to what the sale
what's gonna happen is you know in the
first few episodes and she's she's
wearing the kate kane suit
she's so uncomfortable because first of
all before she turns around everyone
thinks she is kate
and then obviously when she turns around
she's black so she can't be kate
um so she has to try to figure out how
to
make this her own and she goes on the
journey and she redesigns the suit and a
part of redesigning the suit is that she
changes the wig
that goes with the cow thank you for
changing the wig i'm saying this on
camera
so all i'm gonna say is just thank you i
have no idea what this button does
you want to figure it out together my
favorite thing
in episode 201 was watching ryan get
used to the suit and playing with all
the different buttons and figuring
things out
that was me that was me man
let me tell you man when i put that [ __ ]
on for the first time
i looked in the mirror and i realized oh
shoot
i don't know i'm supposed to hold my
hand how am i supposed to hold my hands
and i'm looking at my cast mates and
none of them have played superheroes so
we don't know and i'm just like
am i supposed to do this and then i read
the script and it says
that that's almost like what i'm not
supposed to do so now i'm super confused
so as ryan goes on this journey to
figure out how to be a superhero
to figure out how to be that woman i am
going on this journey to figure out how
to be a superhero and to figure out how
to be that woman
and really those two worlds collide and
like like i think that it's very
authentic like it's a very authentic
journey a lot of times you come into
these superhero shows or movies
and they're already a superhero or
they're they're
they're they have some type of magic
power like that's not to deal with that
one
there's no magic power there's humanity
in
willing to be able to sacrifice and
willing to try to think outside the box
to you know outcome our our villains but
there's definitely
you know the smoothness is not something
i innately have
let's talk about the fact that you get
the batmobile
isn't that epic i mean talk to me about
sitting in it like what's it been like
like is it as cool in person as it
appears on screen
it is as cool in person as it appears in
the screen but even more cool because
i'm actually physically in it
i'm terrified that if i ruin anything
i'm gonna get charged a million dollars
for the car that i can't afford
and then like i said it sits
so low first of all i've already told
you i am not smooth whatsoever
and getting out of that car always
reveals how cleanly i am
because first of all the door is heavy
so i'm trying to open the door
and then finally when i get out i have
to use support to get
up so that i can stand i close the door
my jacket's stuck and i'm like
come on and then it's like the camera's
there so i'm supposed to walk into like
this epic scene
but i can't even get out the car but
it's the batmobile so we make it work
i stumbled on something pretty sick
javici it's been so exciting just from
once they announced your casting
to those first look photos like you've
been on such a roller coaster ride in
addition to all the events that happened
in 2020 what has been the most rewarding
part for you kind of stepping into these
super shoes
to be able to kind of walk away from the
reality of what's happening in society
to be honest
yeah um i'm not blind to it obviously
but to be able to just show up at work
and do what i love
and fly in the air and do these epic
fight scenes and have so much fun with
my co-stars and dancing in the tents and
between
scenes like it's bringing a joy that i
think we all need
um and i hope that our show can reflect
that joy
but that's definitely been like the best
part of this entire situation
what has it meant to you to first of all
play this character
but also just be able to represent so
many diverse
demographics out there it's an honor
that i that me walking in my truth
me walking in my skin me walking in my
shoes
opens doors for other people to be able
to do that
in the biggest capacity ever you know
and and
i think at the end of the day if we
really start to show
true representation on the screen i
think it will start to
relay in other areas in society like the
government
or like other things like that so i you
know it's
it's very necessary i want little little
people
you know in general um little girls
little boys
to feel represented when they see our
characters
on screen i want them to feel like they
see themselves
i want them to feel like the sky is the
limit of what they can be
and i just have a like i i strongly feel
like
if you see it that's when you can
believe it and that's when you can be it
and that's just
like that's just the minimum of what
you're able to accomplish
so if being bad woman is the minimum
i mean the sky literally is the limit
and so yeah i'm really happy that wb
dc you know berlanti we're all willing
to take a chance
using this role as a way to open those
doors give me a chance
and i can bring that hope back to god
[Music]
you